reggie miller the hall of famer joining
us on the program
steps outside of the bubble it goes back
into the bottle bubble
coming up uh on monday and uh he joins
us on the program good morning reg how
are you
good morning theodore and my dad nets
how are you guys doing
we're doing okay we're trying to process
here um
what the lakers are they got everything
figured out now we're all good
nothing to see here we move on to the
second round
false alarm ball movement and when
actually the ball goes in the nets for
these role players how they start
puffing out their chest they get more
active
defensively um but again you and i we've
talked about this
for weeks now when anthony davis
plays at a certain level he takes his
team
to a different level and i think we're
seeing that because the role players
play off because he is the one player in
lebron at times don't get me wrong
every time they touch the basketball
he's gonna command a double team
so caruso and kcp and morris
danny green all these guys feet off
those wide open shots
when they're knocking down shots then
this team is tough to beat because then
lebron has
all these open lanes to get all the way
to the hole
and finish which we've been seeing the
last two ball games
and portland we talked about this i
didn't know if they would come in
on an emotional high which i think they
did in that first game but
now it looks like they're they're on
fumes they're spent a little bit
yeah they're running out of gas and
unless
dame and cj has a big game um
because to me i i've always thought the
blazers have a better supporting cast
in terms of nurkic whiteside carmelo
you know carmelo's had moments you know
during the
the restart um to me i think they have a
better supporting cast
but they have spent so much energy
just to get that eighth seed and then
you know that playing scenario with
memphis dame has been unbelievable he
was the bubble mvp
don't get me wrong but you're right i
think right now
um unless he has a huge game um
this series is arguably over the
clippers
game plan for tonight against luca
is what or should be what
lucas is going to be luca and luke is
going to get his numbers
i think it's almost like with anthony
davis you've got to stop everyone else
it's the heart alright trey berks seth
curry
those guys are the ones who are really
beating you i mean they did this
granted a phenomenal shot by luca
um unbelievable triple double by him
but it's those other guys when he
penetrates and collapse the defense
and finding those spot up threes in the
corners to me that's what's hurting the
clippers
and again they've got to get
i know this is like a a broken record
where's paul jordan where is
paul george and look you give your name
if you're going to give yourself playoff
p the nickname you got to show up
in the playoffs right i mean playoff
paul right has to show up in the
playoffs and he has it
um lou williams has been good kawhi has
been fantastic
but that second piece has to be paul
george
was lucas shot a good shot though reg no
no it wasn't and it wasn't a lucky shot
too because he shoots that all the time
but it was a bad shot made by a great
player
and i've attempted and made a lot of
those bad shots
because he practices those and i think
he'll get better in time
but if you're reggie jackson who was
switched out on him
because if you look at the play kauai
initially started on them
and it was a down screen and what you're
supposed to do is switch
like for like size for size which they
did
but if you're reggie jackson you will
live with
a step back what was that 35 40 footer
you'll live with that who created this
step back
i have no idea but it was probably
my best go-to move
i adopted it from kiki vandalway
um learned it at ucla
we worked on this shot i am not kidding
you
two to three hours a day so he
shot he showed me how to step back left
step back right now
in today's game those guys take it to
james harden takes it to a different
level with the steps
i wish i could have done that ours was a
little bit more
traditional a couple of dribbles and
just
creating that separation lucas is
phenomenal because he has that great
handle and flow to it but uh it was an
unbelievable shot it was a bad shot
but made by a great player so that kind
of lessens the odds a little bit and
then kobe borrowed it from you this step
back right
i taught him i mean this dude asked me
but you knew that you're already giving
one of the top scorers in the game
he wasn't dead he was just a kid he was
a punk kid
skinny with a punk little kid do you
remember
do you remember that day when you talked
i do we were shooting a
a segment or show uh
for the real world if you remember that
back on mtv yeah
and it was he and i versus the real
world
cast and if we won they had to do like
silly chores like
you know we went to the uh we got a
whole bunch of dogs
from the shelter and they had to go wash
them and do errands for us whatever
we knew we were going to be so it was us
two versus like 10 people
and kobe's like i want to destroy him i
want to beat him
like oh let's have fun with his like no
i want to destroy these kids i'm like
all right whatever let's go after them
so in the down time while we were
waiting for them to come back
he's like do you want to play one on one
i'm like dude i'm like i'm gonna play
you one-on-one you know i was
30 he was 19 18 19.
he's like well show me that step back
move that you i gotta know this step
back move i was like okay
well i'll show you that step back move
you show me that crossover because i
love i've always loved his crossovers
he's like sure okay so i'm showing him
the step back left okay
you want the guy on your left hand side
right look at his feet when his feet
start to cross over
that's when you step back he's like okay
but how you do it the other way i was
like okay when you hit the balls in your
left hand
at his waist if he's leaning this way
take a couple steps back
and raise up there's no way and when he
does recover
he's going to follow you because he's
going to be going for your wrist i was
like
so show me that crossover he's like what
are you talking about never showed me
the crossover
never showed me the crossover here i am
giving away
my prize step back move and then lo and
behold what was that
year two years later in the finals
[Music]
this dude is giving me my own move
to me what an idiot i was
idiot we're talking to reggie miller the
hall of famer he'll be back in the
bubble uh starting
next week if the rockets lose this
series
dot dot dot um
i could easily see mike d'antoni
moving on there's some very favorable
job openings but is it the roster or is
it the coach
well the the coach is always the first
to go ask brett brown matt
right he had all that talent i know ben
simmons did not play because of the
injury but he still had talent
still at tobias harris and joelle and b
and you
with those two team two guys on a team
you shouldn't be swept
so the coach is always the first to go
and i think
mike d'antoni and this system look this
system for the rockets was built
to put up a lot of numbers for james
harden
and westbrook who has not played
obviously
and they're under size so they're always
going to get killed on the boards and
they're just going to try to outscore
you
but what's the difference though reg
with golden state in the rockets
in their philosophy they play defense
golden state plays defense okay
okay right they have great shooters but
draymond green
and i know tucker is a defensive minded
guy in austin rivers and all that
but as a whole those teams played
defense they were
top 10 in offense and top 10 in defense
during those championship runs
and you got klay thompson as well uh if
if you could have the nets opening the
pelicans opening of the 76ers opening as
a head coach
who
i probably go with brooklyn because you
have kyrie and
and kd yeah um do you think popovich is
actually interested in that john
is he interested or well they're
interested in him
yeah but do could you see popovich in
brooklyn
with kyrie i could because i think they
have a relationship from team usa
yeah and i think that's they're probably
kind of looking at
a guy that's won championships i know
tyler's name is in the mix
i hope my man mark jackson's name is
being floated around for some of these
some of these gigs as well all three
spots
are very desirable new orleans with a
very young nucleus
the only question mark in my opinion is
zion
and how he's going to come back when
does the season start again
first of all next season and is he going
to come back and shape it how many games
can we get out of them
but what about lonzo ball reg now i
don't know
i mean now i'm hearing that maybe
they're going to try to trade him
i thought that this was the perfect
place for him
it was and i still think it is i think
he had a bad run
i i really do i think he has potential
everyone keeps saying he's going to be
an all-star child player i don't think
he's going to be an all-star type player
but i think he could be a very solid
contributor
because of his skill set his size being
able to run the floor
it's just the shooting the shooting has
failed him before
the stoppage and in the restart
he was shooting the ball fantastic i
don't know if the layoff affected him
but for whatever reason was not able to
find that shot
but new orleans philly brooklyn
uh chicago chicago's another yeah mom
team great city you know if you can
it's cold there but it's a great city if
you can revive that so there's
there's four spots that are very
desirable if you're
a head coach most watchable team in the
east
bucks raptors celtics
heat
i would probably go with wow
that could be your final four too which
would be awesome i would go
see miami's fun to watch i agree because
they are casting a lot of threes duncan
robinson tyler
hero i like the toughness of bam autobio
and obviously jimmy butler
well coached they're a fun team to watch
it's a different style from when you saw
them winning championships
with lebron and d wade and they're just
talk they're tough defensively
um you know what you're going to get
with giannis and that team
um hey look boston and what tatum and
brown
have done in the absence of gordon
hayward and kimba kimber
seems to have found his game now pick a
team reg
the most watchable team in the east is
just because they swept my pacers i'm
going to go with the miami heat
and that's going to be a fun matchup in
the second round
between miami and milwaukee i picked the
celtics one
heat to raptors three bucks four
i tell you this i would not be surprised
if toronto ends up winning
the east i think i said that last week
people keep sleeping on them
they're the defending champs for a
reason and they play a certain style
and those guys know one another so it's
not going to surprise me if toronto wins
the east
um i think in fact i think they have
the clear advantage over those four
teams you mentioned
because they know how to win in crunch
time and fred
van blee has been fantastic in this
restart for them
when bird was your coach in indiana did
you guys ever have shooting contests
no i wanted to ask him
[Music]
but i didn't want to lose to him as well
because i knew he was just wait wait
do you think he would have shot no
that just wasn't his thing his very
first year was probably his
one year because he was doing a lot of
running
then um the next two years for whatever
reason
he wasn't as active in terms of shooting
now he took
money from uh jonathan bender al
harrington
and the rookies because they were dumb
enough not to know
i at least knew larry legend having
faced the celtics and gotten against him
these dudes were puppies and were like
oh my god larry legend
yeah we'll play a horse against you i'm
like dude are you serious
and yeah so he would take money off the
rookies
did you celebrate your birthday
yesterday i did
nice and quiet nice bike ride
solo and the rest was spitting with the
family
it's interesting as you get older and
then your wife goes what do you want for
your birthday
like uh i don't know a nap maybe i
maybe i get to be be by myself today or
something like that well you got little
ones
that was it my two things i was like uh
time
number one i want time time on the bike
so she gave me time on the bike
and she's like well what do you want for
your birthday and i was like wow um
i need underwear so i got cauliflower
underwear
for my birthday let's do this
uh are you surprised that uh montrez
harold didn't get fined by the
the league after be back and forth i
know a lot of things get set on the
floor there reg
but that doesn't mean it's right that a
lot of things get said on the floor
and the fact that i'm surprised there
wasn't a find yeah um
you and i kind of talked text talked
about this
that maybe even a suspension to send a
message
because i always play role reversal what
if luca
had said that to montrez
yeah you know i that's
i like to you know roll reverse everyone
would be up in arms if luca had said
that to montrez
and you're playing on a court that says
black lives matter
and inclusion and acceptance right
so mantra as i know he apologized
and luca accepted it i get it
but still the words were said and i
think there should be some type of
consequence for that but i go back to
isaiah thomas
and dennis rodman what they said about
larry bird but
is like that's not a
i guess they were angry because larry
stole the ball and you know
and they said if he was uh a black
player he'd be just another player i
think
uh and dennis said it isaiah seconded it
and then larry had to go to a press
conference to then go you know
i don't care what they said like larry
didn't care
so that to me and i don't think luca
cares right
but is luke is worse because he's what
he's
i mean he's calling him out in a
negative way i know that they were being
angry about larry saying if he was black
he'd be just another player
lucas that was that was personal
well look uh and it was personal on the
step back
three to tie the series two so
actions mean more to me and i think
that's how zucca is backing up
whatever people are saying about him by
putting up
huge numbers um i'm just saying if
luca had said that about montrezl one of
the players on
the clippers we would still be talking
about it
yes today yeah he would have probably
been suspended
correct um i have luca the over under i
just made it up i said 29 tonight
i'm going under for luca tonight
against the clippers me too i i think
paul george because of what all talk
radio
talk radio has been killing him i think
he
and kawhi have monster games together
i think the over for the here's the
question the over for them is it 65 or
over for paul george
and clyde leonard 65 or over
combined well i can count for 26 from
kauai
paul george you think paul george has a
monster game
i think he does and if he doesn't then
they're in trouble
they're in huge problems i don't think
he goes for 30.
who wins tonight i think the clippers
win all right and then
are we sleeping on the jazz you know
when bogdanovic went out with the
wrist injury i kind of wrote him off and
said you know that was a team good
enough at the beginning of the year to
play for the western conference finals
but
i i didn't give them and then conley
left the bubble
wife had a baby and now here they are
up three games to one uh i will say this
uh donovan spider mitchell has been
fantastic
ingles goldberg they know their roles um
i i feel that is gonna be a lot like the
blazers
when they play the next round knock on
wood that they finish the series out and
face the lakers in the next round yeah
this is perfect for the lakers will they
have spent so much gas
doing what they've done playing great
and then run out of gas against the
lakers
this is set up perfectly for the lakers
to get to the conference finals in my
opinion
this is a perfect team for them to play
safe travels there back into the bubble
and uh nice shirt there i like it thank
you
hello indiana 33 larry legend in indiana
state
hello larry legend man gotta love him
my favorite player growing up i love
magic johnson he raised me at ucla
but i patterned my game after this man
but if you could start
your team with larry or magic magic
for how i play oh man okay yeah
for how i play if i'm on the team yeah
magic how many threes would larry shoot
now
if he played today oh my goodness what
15 to 20
15 to 20. yeah but he always he would
shoot the mid-range jumper and all that
and so that's when the mid-range jumper
meant something i know
these kids that all the time i know
analytics say threes are better than
twos which okay but your percentages are
lower but
there's something to be said with a good
17
to 24 good mid-range game
come on kevin durant built a hall of
fame career off the mid-range jumper
sir demar derozan the mid-range jumper
jimmy roller the mid-range jumper kind
of got him
you know traded out of toronto and
missed out on a championship tomorrow
but
you still have a heck of a mid-range
game yeah great
nice consolation prize uh safe travels
reg thank you bud
thank you to your door